foreign
response of Shame when it does come to
sex but then I feel very lonely and
robbed of connection because of that and
so I'm just kind of at a loss of what to
do for sure man dude uh have you ever
said that out loud before yeah quite a
bit
[Music]
what's up this is John with Dr John
deloney's show
so glad that you're with us on the
greatest mental health and marriage and
parenting podcast of all time ever
I have a history of podcasts which is
about a year and a half maybe
so glad that you're with us you want to
be on the show give me a buzz at
1-844-693-3291 or go to John deloney.com
ask Kelly you're looking through here
and you're making faces as though
something doesn't smell good is it my
face no I figured out I can't do
anything about that
um
no do you were you in that in that photo
session when they're like oh this
picture's perfect oh everything's
perfect the lighting the clothes
everything except for his face and I was
like
oh man no so for those that don't aren't
watching John's
um in ears that he wears his
um
they are different and so this is
they're broken so this is a temporary
pair but it makes it look like you have
earrings on
yeah it's a little distracting so I
think yeah it does look ridiculous it's
cool man we'll get him
look at that that's so cool I kind of
it's like my 80s hair metal band I get
to do it yes that's all right I'll be
there for you
with my long headphone earrings they're
looking good all right um well there we
go so at least
I thought you were just looking at my
face like what happened to his face I
didn't have that ship sailed that ship
sail that just this isn't what I got
that's what I got all right let's go to
Justin in Albuquerque the 505. what's up
Justin
hey John how you doing I'm good my
brother what are you doing
I'm just uh taking a break from shooting
some horses so [ __ ] I had a boy dude
shooting some horses man
out there in New Mexico good for you
brother
yeah so uh but my question is um I guess
I wrote it down it says I'm struggling
with uh my sexual relationship with my
wife I obviously want to have a good one
but I have internal struggles and I feel
a pavlovian response of Shame when it
does come to
um sex even practicing desire feels a
little bit uh shameful for me but when I
uh but then I feel very lonely and
robbed of connection because of that and
so I'm just kind of at a loss of what to
do for sure man dude uh have you ever
said that out loud before
yeah quite a bit
well thanks for making me one of many
that you've said that out loud too so
um when you say shame well let me back
up you said obviously I want this
um that sounds like something that
somebody told you you're supposed to
want
so I would say Obviously off the table
is it something that you want
yeah I I would like that okay I don't
know I just feel
um
I just feel very robbed and I was of
connection and I when I got married I
was I was 21 and uh that's just been not
what I expected and I've been trying to
make the best of it I just don't know
what else to do there you go
um so tell me what shame means what does
that feel like where does that come from
I think well I know for a fact that it
comes from when my parents my parents
got divorced when I was really young and
the only uh and they were both
emotionally absent even though they were
kind of there they were just absent
altogether and so the place that I found
connection at a really young age was
pornography okay and so I was been
struggling you know obviously with that
for
um most of my life and so when I did get
married and I I expected that that
connection to be filled
um you know I turned into my wife's uh
trash can of all her complaints and and
struggles and stuff like that so then I
felt
um I wasn't being heard or or I was just
kind of a trash can as well and so I
I've continued to
um
use that pornography as that that way of
feeling connection so I can get through
uh to the next day okay
does your does your wife know um
there's my wife now uh-huh
yeah we've we've been talking and we're
trying to work through it since uh
before we got married
uh how long have you been married
five four years four years okay does she
know you're still
um using pornography to get through the
day
yeah well not it's not every day but
it's just you know when life gets tough
now it just it it seems like this yeah
okay
um
hmm
there's several places we can go with it
um I I may be way out to lunch here so
sometimes somebody experiences sexual
abuse
um somebody get experiences pornography
at a really young age
and
sex gets lumped in with
I'm dirty right and yeah or kids who
masturbate a lot like or just one right
I'm dirty I'm gross and that gets
translated to when I get married or when
I get into a sexual relationship with
somebody I trust and that I'm with for
the Long Haul
that will all go away and it stuns
people
when they roll over and their bodies
they go right back into the I'm gross
and shameful right or they try to cover
themselves up right it becomes a part of
them right
yeah
um
that's about sex but it's also not
okay so trying to deal with just the sex
part of that is gonna
it's not ever going to get to
why doesn't Justin like himself
and
also
why can't Justin let his needs be heard
by his wife
and why can't she let her needs be heard
by her husband and why can't we stumble
and fumble and practice meeting each
other's needs in ways that we've never
had to do ever before
does that make sense
yeah I think it does that's a different
conversation than I feel gross after
being with my wife or I feel unfulfilled
yeah right does that make sense yeah it
does yeah okay so
the first thing in becoming a new person
right coming up with a new identity this
is who I'm gonna be
is stopping the behaviors
that like Do no harm right I don't know
what to do next but I know to stop doing
this
yeah and tell me what you feel like when
you are starved for connection what does
that feel like in your body
I just feel very uh lonely and uh
easily irritated because I just feel
very uh uh just I get super depressed
and um
I start questioning a lot of things and
what's that
by questioning I mean I honestly I I
question you know
um just because it it's good it's
happened over and over again I just uh
shouldn't like the purpose of life and
stuff so
there's more to that keep going
you're being honest with me don't Don't
Fade Out On Me Now
uh I am
I think that uh
I don't know I just have a lot of
anxiety in my chest right now but a lot
of times I uh
um
when it does come to this it goes
zero to a hundred and feeling uh
suicidal and not not that I'm going to I
just I just I felt so uh
lonely for so long I just don't know
um
I just I just want that connection and
so uh yeah I just feel very
like why why am I here if this is what
life is gonna be like there you go
thank you for saying that out loud
yeah
you've probably had a lot of
conversations about pornography a lot of
conversations about sex a lot of
conversations about hey all you do is
come home and complain to me about your
life
when's the last time you sat down and
looked another person in the eye and
said I'm super lonely and I don't know
what to do
conversation okay
um on Sunday
and um
I I felt I felt heard
but at the same time that
um
you know it kind of goes back to just
how we've been living
um right here's the deal
this is y'all are at a place now where
you've exceeded your capacity to do this
on your own
yeah okay and this is about your life
this is about your joy
and purpose and role it's about your
marriage it's about your family tree
it's about all of it okay
yeah and this is a backyard project that
y'all got to dig in with shovels and all
of a sudden you realized we're sitting
on top of a huge sinkhole we need to
call Professionals in here
because you all can have deep meaning
conversations and I'm proud of you
for Sunday saying
I'm so lonely I don't think I want to be
here anymore I'm proud like that's hard
to say those words out loud
but you say that out loud and neither of
you have the skills to then go okay what
do we do next
what does that look like next
um
you go you just fall back into right
what we've been doing because we don't
know what to do like you see what I'm
saying it's like it's like driving in an
ice patch you start spinning if you
don't already know how to turn into the
spin and how to take your foot off the
gas without hitting the brake and all if
you don't know how to do that
you just keep your foot on the on the
gas and that thing spins faster and
faster until it flies off the bridge
right
yeah
so
what you need today is to reach out to a
professional
in your community and if you've got to
drive drive
if you need to get connected with
um like my friends at better help when
you do it online do it online
okay you have reached you're you are
shoeing a horse right now and you just
realize there's a massive foot infection
you need to call a veterinarian that's
what just happened okay
okay I will tell you
um shame is universal across all
cultures and helps us stay aligned with
our groups okay and if it gets out from
underneath us
that if you do something that violates
your core values right and your picture
of who you should be your identity if
you do something you're about you're
going to feel shame and I'm okay with
that it's when it turns into it becomes
the shame becomes something that becomes
a part of us right or you've heard me
talk about the bricks
if you do something that violates your
core values you're going to pick up a
brick you're going to hold it I did this
thing it's when you put that brick in
your own backpack and say this isn't
something I did this is who I am
okay right and you have to get out of
the I am language
and come up with a new I am
I am a guy who's going to Steward his
mind and his body
I'm a guy who's going to Steward his
marriage
not I'm a guy who's going to quit
looking at porn
okay see what I'm saying yeah it's a
much different proposition to say I'm a
guy who just takes care of his body and
part of that is not just not putting
trash in my mind
I'm a guy who stewards relationships so
that when I start feeling lonely I feel
it way on the front end and I tell my
wife hey I'm feeling disconnected and
we've already met with a counselor and I
know she knows disconnection for me is
sexual it's it's intimacy right I miss
being with you
and some people loneliness means I miss
just sitting and talking with you and
sometimes couples have one of them
disconnection is sexual one of them's
disconnection is is conversational one
of them is disconnected I just want you
to hold me whatever that looks like is
fine
it's being able to have that language in
your relationship and she knows it's not
her fault or maybe part of it it doesn't
matter cool then tonight we're going to
be intimate tomorrow we're going to
knock off work a little bit earlier
whatever that look you see what I'm
saying we're gonna create some language
in our house because
not because we're trying to quit we're
trying to quit Justin from looking at
porn no
because we're a couple that stewards our
marriage
there were a couple that stewards our
bodies I just eat right not because I'm
trying to cut carbs I eat right because
on on me I'm a guy who takes care of his
body see what I'm saying yeah it's a
totally different proposition right so
I want you to remember this with all of
your heart
it's from the great brene Brown the
shame researcher
shame eats secrets for breakfast is how
she says it
if you have secrets in your marriage and
in your home and in your friend
relationships
your body it has a physiological
consequence it will cost your body okay
okay means when you're feeling
disconnected at the very front end and
you try to hide it from your wife and
you know once that that Domino gets hit
and it starts going and knocking all the
other dominoes down you know where this
ends up it ends up you wait for your
wife to go to the grocery store and then
you pull out the laptop and now you're
Off to the Races and you're already
feeling bad as it's happening but it
also you can't stop it right
yeah okay the moment you start feeling
disconnected on a Tuesday instead of it
waiting until Thursday or Friday you
tell your wife I'm starting to feel
disconnected
okay that's Secrets okay and she is
going to learn
through professional counseling that
y'all two are going to go to together
y'all are gonna learn
um
you're gonna learn how to hear that
those needs from each other without it
setting off your alarms now you
mentioned your parents you come from a
house where you're neglected
they had their own lives and you were
just a bother
okay
recognize in your body that it has
identified relationships as something to
be avoided because they hurt
you got a little boy inside of you that
for his whole life has been asking
what's what's wrong with me why wouldn't
they talk to me
there must be something screwed up
inside of me is that is that fair is
that right yeah
and now you have a need
and you're married you've got somebody
who's committed in front of her friends
and God I'm going to be here to meet
your needs and you're going to be there
to meet mine
and all of a sudden that relationship
alarm starts going off and you withdraw
and you go to nameless anonymous
pseudo-intimate sources on the internet
because it's safer than entering into a
relationship because you did that once
when you were a kid and both your
parents said nah we don't want you
yeah right so here's the deal it's like
um
it's like you fell off a cliff into a
raging River and you almost drown
you still got to get out of that River
dry off but you have to have water that
night to drink because your body has to
have it to live right you can't just
avoid water forever you gotta have
relationships to be able to breathe
okay so you gotta teach your body that
relationships used to not be not be safe
not be okay now they are
see what I'm saying that's the journey
you're on you're gonna retrain your body
same with dealing with your horses that
previous owner abused you
I'm going to prove to you over time that
I'm not you're teaching that horse that
relationships are now safe because they
used to not be get what I'm saying yeah
you're that you're that horse okay
okay and so every time you feel your
body start to get annoyed at your wife
or get feel sharp with her
ask yourself what is my body trying to
protect me from
not okay why won't she you see what I'm
saying there's a total difference there
why oh I'm starting to get close I'm
starting to realize I need her right now
and my body's like oh no no no we're not
gonna do that again
and this is when you have to learn the
skills to go nope that's exactly what
we're doing we're going directly into
the into the mouth of this dragon
see what I'm saying
yeah absolutely it's something you
practice
um will you commit to 30 days
of staying off the computer
yeah I will
every time you
think you want to or you feel like you
need to I'll even go that far and need
to if you've been doing a long time it's
it's absolutely as as much as any
addiction as heroin is
um
will you write it down go to Walmart or
go to get on Amazon and order a cheap
Journal write it down here's what time
it was during the day here's what I feel
like
here's what's going on in my head as I
am feeling this call to do this and then
I want you to go for a run go for a walk
call a friend go do something go ride a
horse whatever okay
okay put on the calendar 30 days
okay Mark it off cool
yep all right well after this I want you
to tell your wife
um
you and I are gonna go see somebody and
I'm going to make the call for us would
she be in that into that for you
oh yeah yeah absolutely good hey you're
about to change everything
hey one more thing one more thing Justin
do you promise
if you think about hurting yourself that
you'll call somebody
yeah absolutely
you promise promise
yeah yeah I don't believe you
yeah I promise that I'll uh talk to
somebody just because it's not I don't
it's not that I I want to be gone I just
want to feel
um
yeah
I feel loved yeah absolutely you want
it's not that you want to be dead as you
want the pain to stop
yeah
and by the way dude
you are loved
you're not you're not loved in a way
that makes sense to your that little
seven-year-old boy
because your mom and dad probably told
you we love you and then they
disappeared on you
yeah and so your body's trying to figure
out what the crap that even means
and your journey is to figure out this
is what feeling loved feels like because
you don't know right now that's okay
it's a skill You're Gonna Lose yeah it's
something you're gonna practice
and you're gonna get some dudes in your
life that you love and respect and iron
sharpens iron you're gonna do life with
right
okay
okay hang on the line I'm going to send
you a copy
um in fact I'm gonna send you two copies
of
um own your past change your future my
book okay and I want you and your wife
to read it together
and highlight it this is going to give
y'all a conversation I will read a
chapter a week right and we're gonna
read it and we're gonna talk about what
we read and what we highlighted in it
and we're gonna start to
look at the little GPS pins of trauma in
our life that our bodies pegged for us
we're going to start looking at those
moments and our bodies start to feel a
little bit weird and we're going to call
a counselor
we're playing a long game with this one
and dude I'm real optimistic I'm real
optimistic 30 days I expect you to email
me back Justin and let me know I made 30
days
[Music]
30 days again after that but we're going
to do 30 days to start off with why
because you're a guy that takes care of
himself you're the guy that stewards his
body you're a guy that stewards his
marriage
and we're going to start there creating
a new Justin moving forward we'll be
right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spinning
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step
when you're facing problems or
challenges in life it's way too easy to
get stuck in that anxious spiral of Doom
I've been there but when you learn how
to stop that cycle and start taking
ownership of your life that's when
you're free and that's what therapy can
help you do it gives you the tools you
need to do the problem solving in your
own life and that's why I love better
help better help is online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist it's more
affordable than in-person therapy plus
you can be matched with a therapist in
under 48 hours if you're ready to get
the tools that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's thrown at you therapy
can help visit betterhelp.com deloni to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com deloney
all right we are back hey Kelly I'm
wired out of my mind this morning I went
to coffee shop to meet a buddy and I
ordered a red eye you know what that is
uh yeah it cost me with a bunch of
espressos in it evidently it's also
like a martini
it's like a martini with espresso in it
or something
and so I ordered it and the waiter came
to the table and they never do that it's
like a you go to the counter in order
and you go sit down and he said uh I
need to see an ID and I looked in and I
was like
this must be the most like Nitro fueled
coffee ever what do you put in this
thing he's like the mark for the red eye
martini and it was like 7 15 and then he
goes
yeah I need to see your ID man like if
you're gonna get going this early I need
to make sure and I was like I
I just want some coffee man that's it
did you drink the martini well I had six
of them no I'm kidding no those plates a
lot no I had to I just I had the
I had the bread I'm in and then I had
regular coffee and um I had other coffee
here on the table I'm I'm ready to go
it's good and I saw you pretty much
Mainline some sugar before we left the
office it was yesterday yeah so I was
tired coming back from we had those two
sold out shows of Phoenix man I'm just
coming back kind of tired you need to
get some sleep this weekend I agree to
disagree all right let's go to Tamara in
H-Town what's up Tamara go Astros
hi Dr John how are you I'm good how are
you
I'm good awesome what's up
um so I just have um a question so I
sort of been struggling
um
with
like getting close to my stepson
and like feeling that love
for him like I should in a way
um
so tell me more
so we got custody of him like have
custody about a year ago
um and before that you know we would
just have him like every other weekend
and stuff and my husband was obviously
fighting really hard to get half custody
and how old is this little boy
he is seven seven how long have you been
married
we have been married for two years two
years
were you previously married too
um never married I was in a previous
relationship for like nine years and I
had a daughter in that relationship
um
and my daughter's eight so they're kind
of close in age sure
um
yeah so
whenever before we got have custody we
had like full custody
for a time because there was like the
situation situation that happened
um
and so we ended up getting full custody
for like a whole summer pretty much okay
and during that time I wasn't working so
the caretaking pretty much fell on me
okay
um and I feel like I struggled a lot my
husband and I had a lot of issues during
that time
um we almost got a divorce why why
because as you're saying this I'm
thinking this has nothing to do with
that little boy
no no during the time when we were going
to get divorced it was mostly like
Financial issues um he was like on the
Ramsey
blank Gun Hill about Ramsay and I wasn't
and we just had a bunch of issues we
started seeing a financial counselor and
we fixed that we pretty much got on the
same page and ever since then my husband
and I have been great but I feel like
this thing with my stepson has me
feeling
like I'm struggling
and what's what's the struggle is he
loud is he annoying is he a brat is he
is he not feeling like your daughter
feels like what what is the thing you're
struggling with
um well yeah pretty much you said it
like he's just very loud
um kind of body just stuff that I'm not
used to like my with my daughter she's
just very chill very laid back
um I had all girls in my family like
nothing but sisters
um cousin pretty much girls and so I
wasn't used to voice welcome to the
Terra Dome Tara Tamara
you're in it now
I know so with him I was like oh my
goodness like is this how boys I you
know he's he's a lot
um that's the exact words my wife used
to describe me
um what's it like living with John and
she
it's it's a lot it's
it's yeah yes not every boy some boys
are quiet some boys are are do their own
thing and
some boys are maniacs
yeah yeah it sounds like you have some
expectations about what you're supposed
to feel and how kids are supposed to be
and that's the issue here I don't ever
want to punish a seven-year-old boy for
being a seven-year-old boy all right let
me say punish I don't want to dislike a
seven-year-old boy for being a
seven-year-old boy
yeah exactly and
um I
of divorced parents okay so I had you
know step parents um my stepdad
sort of like didn't really care for us
um you know he I to this day I've never
had a real conversation with my stepdad
like he just didn't care much for us so
will you change that
I'm sorry are you going to change that
with my stepdad nope can't can't oh yeah
that one's got appeared at the end but
now you're a step parent
yes and you get to change what happens
moving forward are you gonna are you
gonna do that
yes I want to that's why
I'm here do you ah there we go Okay so
before I walk you through it do you want
to or do you want to want to
yeah
um
because if you want to it's going to
require you to do different things
yeah if you want to want to then you
just have to wait until you decide you
actually want to make some changes in
your life
yeah
I want to okay
so I'm going to tell you something
that's hard and is not politically
correct is that cool
okay I don't care about how you feel
as the adult I care more about right now
what you do
okay
you can't compare him
to your the feelings and connection you
have with your daughter
okay it's gonna feel different
especially right now
and especially because they're so
different right
and so comparing them of total Fool's
Aaron man you're gonna you're gonna
you'll crash that that into the into the
ditch I called A buddy of mine who's
um has somewhat of a similar situation
just walk through like hey what are some
things you experience in the house where
some things your wife experienced that
so
um comparison is what's going to kill
you the second thing is is you've got to
let completely go your preconceived
notions of what full custody was going
to mean I think you're still hanging on
you fought for for custody you were all
in until you like oh this is what a
seven-year-old boy in the house feels
like and looks like
um how does p get everywhere right how
does it get everywhere it just does
um you're gonna have to let those
preconceived notions go and let your
seven-year-old be who your
seven-year-old is
yeah my guess is that summer that you
spent
you had some preconceived notions about
that Summer's going to look like and all
of a sudden you ended up and it was July
and you were basically just a caretaker
of your new husbands
kid
and it was less about
I bet you're fun to hang out with but it
was less about that and more about I
didn't sign up for this or I had
different expectations for this and now
my life is different than I thought it
was going to be is that fair
okay
um
so I care way more about what you do
have you had like a weekly date with him
just us two
um I'm gonna take him out to for
breakfast or dinner just us too
it's been
it's been um but yeah I I agree that I
feel like I should do more of that with
him it's not it's not big huge grand
gestures it's not like I gotta take him
to Disneyland It's not that it's the
tiny little things that he hasn't had in
a long time
once uh once a week you get breakfast
with stepmom
and we're gonna pick some restaurant I
eat a waffle house with my kid and I
literally am dying every time I have
breakfast I know this
um but the time with him is worth it
right I mean from what I'm eating but I
it's it's it's a great time with him but
it's always on the calendar and so
letting him know relationally I'm gonna
keep showing up I'm gonna invest in you
little things like hey give me a list of
books and movies you like I'm reading an
old Michael Crichton book right now
because I'm doing a book exchange with
my son and it wouldn't have been a book
that I picked but I'm trying to get into
it so I can get into his world and I can
talk to things he's interested in see
what I'm saying and ultimately he's
gonna remember dad invested in me dad
came to my world sometimes and didn't
always drag me along to his and so I'd
love you to make a list of music a list
of I my son the other day got in the
truck and you've probably heard me talk
about his love for 90s country I had
like a I don't know Garth Brooks or
Brooks and Dunn there I don't know CD in
my my CD player in the truck
um and he's like Dad what are you
listening to and I said I'm listening to
this because I love you
and he beamed right so you may have to
grit your teeth through some new hip-hop
artist or through some new pop country
art I don't I don't care we're gonna
teach him that I'm investing in you okay
and then the little thing would he give
you a hug every day
uh
see that's what gets me sometimes
because he's so like cuddly and
you know just like very he's he's a
sweet boy
um
and sometimes I I struggle with like
feeling you know that or like
he'll come up and hug me when I get home
sometimes he'll come before my daughter
does and like give me a big hug and why
why does that why does that catch why
don't you like that
or why don't you see that for what it is
which is a little boy saying am I safe
do you love me
I don't I don't know okay
what do you feel when he hugs you
annoyed frustrated get away from me what
do you feel
um
like
I would say
just
you say what
maybe annoyed because I don't feel like
that connection
um
so yeah what's the what what is the
connection gonna feel like
foreign
like it does when you know my daughter
comes up to hug me or something it will
never feel like that
would you do that to a seven-year-old
like in the mall
would I
yeah or would you if a seven-year-old in
the mall or like at a church or
something came up to give you a hug
would you be like uh
um
probably
um
probably
[Laughter]
well there's never been like a really
like honey thank you for being honest so
it's actually a person so here's an
here's an important thing
number one you can teach him boundaries
by saying
I'm not a big hugger but I do like this
let's come up with a secret handshake
together
or
um you can practice
not quote unquote feeling like a hug but
still hugging this little seven-year-old
boy anyway
okay that's what adults do
is they do the right thing even though
they quote unquote don't feel like it I
didn't feel like working out this
morning you do it anyway right yeah
um now when it comes to your body
there's a little bit that's a little bit
different so there may come Seasons when
you say I don't want him bearing his
head in my chest and I don't want him
nuzzling up on me that's fine here's how
we're gonna do this instead right so but
we're not we're not starving him and
cutting him off because right now he's
wondering what was so bad about him that
his mom left
what was so bad about me that Dad made
mom go away
I guess I know but his whole world has
exploded
and he's coming to you every time saying
am I safe
yeah do you love me and your body is
telling him oh
seventh grade boy gross our
seven-year-old boy gross
second grader don't do that
yeah okay even if you don't feel like it
that connection with that kid doesn't
mean you have to nuzzle up to him
doesn't mean you have to like I there's
a there's a fine line here but it's
right let me ask you this hard question
um and I may be out to lunch here okay
is there something about seeing him
well let me preface it this way
um I had a girlfriend for a long time
before I got married I've been married
20 years
um and I'm friends with all all almost
all my uncle friends like I I am cordial
would say hi to them
um all that so it's not like a weird
thing
um my wife told me once
I'll always be jealous of so and so I
said why we've been married for two
decades
and the response was so insightful
and she said because she'll always have
something I don't have and I was like
what's that and she said five more years
of knowing you
She'll always be ahead of me and it
never occurred to me
um and again that jealousy is not like
she's my wife's waking up in the middle
of the night with lipstick on the right
drawing on the mirror right nothing like
that but it's this idea like
there's always a little tiny I didn't
know you as a freshman she did in high
school I didn't know you as a weird
awkward junior in high school she did
right so is there something about
seeing this little boy
that reminds you or acknowledges that
your husband had another life before you
have to do with like
um he has a lot of his mom's qualities
like you know he's sort of like negative
he can be very negative very
um he can be a little manipulative
sometimes
um okay hold on hold on you are putting
adult
um
adult issues
on a child
yeah
ex-wife may be super manipulative
seven-year-old little boy is trying to
figure out a way to get an adult to love
him because the other adults in his life
blew up his life
yeah very very different
even if both of the actions look the
same right
a lying seven-year-old is different than
a lying 30 year old lying's not good but
one of them signals something uh you see
what I'm saying
yes yes so don't put adult
characteristics adult issues into the
heart and mind of that little
seven-year-old
and you opted into this marriage into
this relationship with a guy who had
been on another honeymoon before who
made another human before you did too by
the way
and so don't punish the seven-year-old
for your insecurities for your husband's
past for his crazy ex is a crazy ex-wife
that little seven-year-old doesn't
deserve that you see what I'm saying
and the path through that is you making
peace with the relationship that you
chose which is this new marriage
and it's you making peace with you're
enough
does your husband walk around wishing he
had his ex-wife back
you know okay then don't start don't
walk around you don't walk around that
house saying well I used to have another
woman that he loved don't do that don't
do that why that's just choosing to be
miserable right and I want you to
practice doing new things with this
little boy
even when you quote unquote don't feel
like it
here's what I'm gonna do I'm gonna send
you the questions for humans for kids
okay okay and I want you to commit to
two months that's eight breakfasts with
him in a row so that there's some sort
of routine
and take these cards it's all you have
to do is take these cards just you two
together
um and ask him some of these questions
okay
okay that's it and he asks you you got
to be honest and answer and if he
actually says something funny laugh
and if he comes at you to hug you and
his hands are covered in frogs and worms
or whatever else you can grab his wrist
and say hold on go wash your hands
and you're teaching him
hygiene and hospitality and then you're
going to give him that hug
even though he looks like his mom even
though he looks he acts like his your
husband's EX
because he's just a little
seven-year-old boy wondering
are you gonna leave me too
okay are you gonna leave him
no I don't want to no no no I don't want
to what's Yoda say there is no try are
you gonna leave him
no okay
rest on that exhale on that I'm gonna be
here
so what does that mean that means I get
to decide what this relationship looks
like moving forward and since I'm the
adult I'm gonna do things even I don't
quote unquote feel like them
I'm gonna I'm gonna use my energy to
connect with this kid this kid is going
to graduate high school and he's going
to have some challenges because the
divorce was a big deal the fighting is a
big deal the back and forth with Mom and
the dad acts all that is that's a big
deal
this kid will never Wonder
if I loved him
he's never going to wonder if I would
show up if he needed me
because I'm gonna have laid a path that
he knows exactly who I am and how much
he means to me and you as the adult are
gonna have to practice that
and don't compare them to your daughter
but never gonna be the same never gonna
be the same and that's okay
thank you so much for the call Tamara
you're a brave brave uh stepmom lean
into it we'll be right back
it seems like everybody's talking about
how crazy the housing market is right
now and how powerless home buyers feel
mix that with the stress of moving and
life change and job change and you've
got a tornado of anxiety fueling one of
the biggest purchases you'll ever make
this is not a good idea so if you're a
new home buyer right now my advice to
you is to focus on what you can control
like the people you choose to help you
in the home buying process you need
folks like my friends at Churchill
Mortgage Churchill is a Ramsay trusted
provider that's been helping people with
their home mortgages for decades and
their home buyer Edge program will help
you skip a bunch of the stress here's
how it works apply to become a Churchill
certified home buyer and cap your
interest rate for 90 days then you'll
get a five thousand dollar seller
guarantee to help your offer stand out
so go ahead take a deep breath because
Churchill has your back check them out
at churchillmortgage.com deloney and get
the home buyer Edge today this is a paid
advertisement an MLs ID 1591 nmls
consumeraccess.org equal housinglender
1749 Mallory Lane Suite 100 Brentwood
Tennessee 37027 programs are for select
loan types only and not available in all
states or locations
all right we're back let's take one more
unamas let's go to Claire in
Pennsylvania what's up Claire how we
doing
this is so exciting I'm excited to talk
to you what's happening
um okay so I had a baby nine weeks ago
congratulations and thank you
um and since then I have been so annoyed
with my husband
um everything well like the first two
weeks I actually think I hated him yeah
everything he did just oh I made my skin
crawl I just had this like visceral
reaction it was terrible and what I'm
laughing with you not at you like so no
what was he doing what was he doing
well so that's what made it worse is he
was doing everything like he was being
so good he was like helping with the
baby and like he was keeping the house
clean like he did nothing wrong okay and
yet I still was like I just had this uh
I was just so annoyed
um and so you know that was like the
first couple weeks and since then it's
gotten a lot better okay but I'm still
like
I don't know I still get very annoyed
when
just I guess at him in general and again
it's like for no reason like he's still
he's an amazing husband and I like
logically I know like I'm so grateful
but just I just can't like shake these
feelings of just annoyance
um so and I'm sick of it like I really
want to feel loving for my husband again
um
but and you know like we have such good
communication like he knows how I'm
feeling and we've talked about it so
much and talking about it does help but
like I still have these like lingering
feelings of annoyance and I really want
to get rid of them so
one uh
number one you're awesome thank you for
you just you just clarified what
millions of new moms feel and experience
in a very clear and concise way so thank
you for doing that okay that's
comforting then it's not just me you're
not insane no okay
um
I'm trying to think where to where
annoyance doesn't mean you don't love
him number one
don't equate those two things
number two
feelings are very very important and
they lie to you
and part of dealing with a new body a
new life you have a kid now with a new
husband because he's a new guy he's got
a child he's the same dude looks the
same smells the same leaves his
underwear in the same pile totally
different totally different guy now
right so yeah yeah it doesn't mean you
love him
it means y'all got to build something
completely new now I want to ask you
something you have to tell me the truth
you promise I promise okay I promise
I don't fully believe you so convince me
there's something he's doing that's
driving you crazy what is it
yeah
okay
go for it okay so what when we got home
from the hospital
he was like I think he was and we
listened to him anyway he was like
trying to be super dead I think and I
felt like the only thing I was doing was
nursing the baby and then he would take
the baby and change the baby and play
with it's like you know and put the baby
down and everything and like at first
I think I felt like I like was being
robbed of like
being his mom kind of does that make any
sense at all a thousand percent it does
okay so
um like I said like we had talked about
that and like we've sort of just a
couple days ago we kind of had the
conversation about like our new roles
like what his role as dad looks like and
like what my role as mom looks like and
it's been much better since then but I
think that was the thing that sort of
like Set It Off is just like I felt like
like I have been like looking forward to
being a mom like my whole adult life so
I was so excited to have the baby and
then it felt like all I was doing was
feeding the baby which of course is
important but like I wanted to do all
the other things too and so what you ran
into a super common thing you've heard
me talk about this a million times on
the show you had a very distinct picture
of what mom was going to be
and you had a picture of what dad was
going to be
and he had a very distinct picture of
what being a dad was going to be like
and what your role as a mom was going to
be like
and both of you went into that with the
greatest of motives in the highest love
for one another and for that little baby
and you just pass each other in the
night because you had different
you used words and the words were mom
and dad but the pictures of what that
looked like were very different
yeah right and so all we have to do is
align here's what dad's gonna mean for
us
here's what Mom is going to mean for us
and then we're gonna live into that
picture your husband sounds like an
awesome guy who was like I'm not gonna
be that Dad
who just sits there watching football
I'm going to be this and you sound like
an awesome Mom who was I want to
experience all of this I've carried this
knucklehead for nine months I want to
experience all of it all the and I don't
want to be that Mom that's like whining
about her husband all the time and then
in an effort to love each other great
y'all forgot to ask each other what that
meant
you are now you're frustrated you're
annoyed with him whatever okay so
let your annoyance not be something
you're scared of let it be a
um traffic signal
just giving you a heads up that there's
probably something you haven't spoken
out loud yet
and you will find if you speak something
out loud and your husband does something
you won't be frustrated or annoyed
you'll be pissed all right your body
will let you know I specifically said I
am changing diapers and he's like I
changed all the diapers right you'll be
angry you won't be annoyed annoyance is
usually me not speaking my boundaries
and somebody Crossing them and not
knowing they crossed them
okay so I just have to figure out what
that is exactly and so ask yourself with
joy with a smile on your face ask
yourself what's my body trying to tell
me right now what is he doing right now
that I would like to be doing
but you see how important it is to be
curious and not judgmental
curious about it oh man I'm starting to
be really annoyed at that dude
it's because he's singing and I want I
had a picture of quiet tonight all you
have to do is say hey can I have like
I've been listening to this baby cry all
day can we have some quiet and he'll go
oh yeah sure right I know and he will
you know like I know he totally will if
I just asked him he would he would do
anything you know okay so now you're in
how long have y'all been married
uh three years okay you're in you're in
part two
congratulations you just went to level
two in marriage
all right
yeah it was a big jump
oh and they don't tell you at any stuff
right but here's here's what part two
means part two means before you had baby
y'all could just make out whenever you
wanted wherever you wanted you could
just spend whatever dumb money you
wanted on whatever dinner you want you
could just wake up at midnight and be
like hey you just want to go eat ice
cream be like yeah let's do that
now your life is different you can't do
that anymore
or you can once a year right and then
you just get gassy when you eat ice
cream in the middle of the night it's
not even worth it
so so nothing has changed and everything
has changed
and so instead of getting home at 5 pm
and him being able to just nod his head
to you across the room and you know oh
gosh he wants to hook up again and we're
just gonna do it now you got to put on
the calendar
right now instead of just leaving the
room because he's singing
now you got a baby and you can't just
get up and leave the room you gotta tell
him hey please stop singing
so now we're going to be more
intentional about letting our needs be
heard and that takes a lot more risk
because when we let our needs be heard
the our partner can say no I'm not doing
that and so it's more vulnerable As you
move up levels it becomes more
vulnerable see what I'm saying yeah yeah
so I feel like I'm not great at speaking
my needs anyway so none of us are none
of us are right and so you're going to
practice it but it's letting him know
hey I am going to start speaking my
needs and I want you to start speaking
your needs and this is going to be
awkward and weird for both of us
we can need to you
and you are going to instantly be filled
up with Shame about it
I can't believe you had to ask me for
this or you're going to be filled up
with anger does you know what I'm doing
every day and you have to commit to not
letting those feelings you can feel them
it's fine but they're not telling you
the truth
and you're gonna have to say okay he
husband did what he said he was going to
do he's expressed his needs now I get to
decide whether I'm going to meet those
needs and how and then you got to do the
same thing for him
yeah right
yeah no it makes sense and annoyance is
just a signal that's just a signal
okay good you're not you're not I was
getting scared by my annoyance so I'm
glad no no no you're not broken you're
not broken at all right usually I
thought you were gonna say this usually
when I talk to
you you're nine nine weeks or nine
months
nine weeks okay nine weeks as to
it's used about month three or four that
husbands are like well when are we gonna
start hooking up again you know I mean
and and so that's usually when people
are like I'm super annoyed with him like
I just I am I want my body back I'm
feeding a kid my body's still trying to
get back into its original shape now
this guy's Pawling at me I just want all
right you're not there yet possibly but
you'll be there soon
he's giving me some looks and I've kind
of shot him down
that's right that's right yeah so it
will morph from look to
so uh right and so here's the deal
let's commit now to speaking our needs
out loud
and really his need like his like dude
when are we gonna that's really often
code for I miss my wife
um
and that's different than I just want to
get off like right see what I'm saying
so we're just going to be curious we're
going to be not judgmental with each
other and we're going to practice
speaking our needs out loud and then by
the way you're gonna have all kinds of
bananas feelings it's all good you know
what else you're gonna feel I'm really
annoyed at that kid
and then you know what you're gonna feel
really guilty that you felt annoyed yeah
and then you're gonna feel really
shameful that you felt guilty it's just
ah it's all it's and it's all it's all
lies
in this part of the fun right it's part
of the fun yeah it's super annoying to
bring us full circle
so Claire you're a great mom
thank you great wife
and you're just in level two and you
just got to do you're gonna have to
learn new skills in this one and by the
way you're gonna have another kid and
he's gonna get a new job and then you're
gonna think about going back to work or
not going back to work and then you're
gonna go to level three and this whole
thing keeps moving right yeah yeah so
I'll leave you with this the great
Esther perel says
the average adult has four or five great
loves in their lifetime in their adult
lifetime
and if they work really hard it's with
the same person
but I am not the guy my wife married not
even close that guy was an idiot
and I'm not who I was 15 years ago thank
goodness I'm not who it was 10 years ago
I'm especially not who I was five years
ago four years ago especially not
so all that to say is my wife has had to
keep
okay I'm now married to this guy
I'm now married to this guy I am now
married to this guy and I've had to do
the same thing with her
she's a radically different woman than
the person I married and so the the
adventure and excitement and joy of
marriage is
what do you need how can I mate help
meet your needs and here's what I need
that's not what you needed last season
you're right it's a new season now just
like in the summer I need shorts and a
t-shirt in the winter I need coat and
jacket I'm still the same guy my needs
just change and that happens all the
time and if you can unhook from this is
the way he quote unquote is supposed to
be this I'm supposed to feel and this is
what is oh man now you're in for a
for an incredible adventure with a
partner
on to wherever y'all end up and that my
friend Claire
that's the magic that's the magic we'll
be right back
hey what's up now that my new book oh in
your past change your futures out in the
wild we've been hearing reviews and
feedback from readers and wow I'm so
grateful and one of the things I've been
most excited about hearing is that this
book is not just for people who are
healing from terrible traumatic
experience or other big scary things
from their past this book is for
everyone in every Walk of Life the
single 30 year old looking to sharpen
their mind the 25 year old hoping to
make new friends the parent who's tired
of seeing their kids eyes glued to a
screen but who doesn't know how to
re-enter their life people coming out of
abusive relationships everyone and this
book isn't me talking at you this book
is me walking with you because I've been
there too to better understand and
improve your mental relational and
emotional health please check out own
your past change your future at John
deloney.com today that's John
deloney.com today
all right as we wrap up today's show
um this is not James Blunt yeah
beautiful not that song this is James
Bay
best fake smile
and it goes like this
no you don't have to wear your best fake
smile don't have to stand there and burn
inside
ah and if you don't like it
she's working late and making eyes at
the door she's sick of everybody up on
her floor she wants the sun in her eyes
but all she gets is ignored she used to
put it out and get it all back and now
she's slipping trying to carry the ACT
she's sweating Under The Lights now
she's beginning to crack whoa
you don't have to care so don't pretend
nobody needs the best fake friend don't
hide it that's what we're here for we're
not hiding nothing we'll see you soon